all over the world
species clash in nature's savage battle
of survival
on land under the sea
and in the air
all are locked in deadly conflict
animals fight tooth and claw to win food
territory
and rights to the bloodline
from africa to asia there are no rules
this is animal fight night
it's spring
and this grizzly is emerging from
hibernation
and he's bad news
a large standing grizzly can top eight
feet tall
and weigh in at around 1500 pounds
muscles in his shoulders back and
buttocks make him five times stronger
than the average human male
[Applause]
his brute force is backed up by four
inch long claws
and 42 teeth in his bone-crushing jaws
the mountain ranges of north america are
home to another heavyweight predator
cougars can be as much as 250 pounds of
lean mean killing machine
they relentlessly hunt down everything
from a small snack to a whole meal
the muscle-bound hindquarters are the
power base for leaping on their prey
the front paws and razor-sharp one-inch
claws are flesh-piercing slash-and-grab
weapons
this particular cougar will now have to
kill larger prey every few days
she's a new mother
with growing cubs to feed
but for the grizzly they're just
helpless parcels of tender meat
and he's a ruthless killer
perfectly equipped with super strong
senses to track them down
the area of mucous membrane inside his
nose is 100 times larger than a human's
giving him a sense of smell seven times
more powerful than a bloodhounds
sensing danger the mother moves the cubs
undercover
but it's too late
and it's his brute force up against the
claws and cunning of the cougar
the grizzly attempts a 1500 pound charge
but it's uphill
and the cougar rushes to meet him
she's chosen the higher ground to mount
our defense
charge block
the grizzly goes for sheer muscle power
he tries to barge his way through like a
killer linebacker
he shakes from side to side creating a
moving target
but the cougar has the tactical
advantage
she can't match the bear's bulk
but she can get a good angle on it and
she's a speed and power combo
she whips in a lightning fast one two
with her paws
and looks for a lethal spine bite
she aims her powerful jaws to try and
drive her canines like pick hammers
between the vertebra at the base of his
skull
using this grip she can even snap the
spinal cord of a fully grown elk
the grizzly still holds the advantage of
massive strength and the cooler can't
reach her mark
it's an uneasy standoff
the grizzly's goal is mouth-wateringly
close
but the cougar's agility is a fierce
match for all his power
the cougar still holds the higher ground
the grizzly cracks first
avoiding eye contact
this fight's not worth the risk for such
small morsels
the cougar smells victory
and that's how you get a grizzly
running scared
brute force is no match for tactical
skill
and a mother's determination
but thirst drives animals to take huge
risks
the luangua river in east africa
large mammals are drawn here to seek
relief from the dry heat
but they must never let down their guard
because a terrible danger
lurks below
the nile crocodile is a colossus of the
riverbank
it can reach up to 20 feet in length
and 2 000 pounds in body weight
propelled by its muscular tail it hones
in on its prey
and once it has a target in its sights
there's little hope of escape
adults can survive for many months on
one meal
but when a dwindling water supply
concentrates the food source
it's time to take advantage and chow
down
but another mammoth mud lover seeks out
water
and these hard cases are not about to be
pushed around by their scaly neighbor
hippos may be grass eaters
but they're also fearsome fighters
males weigh nearly 10 000 pounds
they are the super heavyweights of the
watering hole
the tough hide on his back is two inches
thick and he's armed with 18-inch
canines razor-sharp and fiercely pointed
their massive mouths can open up to an
angle of 150 degrees
dangerous is their default setting
and they could easily snap a croc in too
this cramped herd is in a state of high
tension
they want this watering hole to
themselves
they've got their vulnerable calves to
protect
but this six-year-old female croc is
ready to eat
she's got a baby hippo in her sights
any crop would be crazy to put the
temper of this herd to the test
but this is a croc with extreme attitude
she's not the sort to respect boundaries
she's the sort to cross the thin line
between brave and reckless
she sneaks toward the center of the herd
she's definitely in the wrong place
and with hippos it's never the right
time
the herd sense is dangerous
and attack like a squadron of battle
tracks
the crocs overwhelmed by sheer numbers
she tries to slip away
but her luck runs out just a few feet
from safety
the hippos corner her again
one grips her body
a second goes for her head
while another grabs her tail
the hippo's mouths contain a clutch of
cutthroat razors
the rasping action between their upper
and lower canines keeps them keenly
sharpened
a direct hit can slash through skin as
well as impale their enemies
it's curtains for the croc
but it's not just hippos who have killer
teeth
her jagged jaw holds 68 teeth
and she has one of the most powerful
bites in nature
her jaws clamp tight with an amazing 5
000 pounds of force
so her grasp nearly always spells
death bites down hard on the hippo
it's a game changer
creating enough chaos for her to wriggle
free to the bank
after being just one snap away from
oblivion
this young croc decides there's a lot to
be said for life on the fringes
plundering and pillaging is a way of
life on the high seas
this is the magnificent frigate bird
one of the most notorious pirates of the
caribbean
it has an eight feet wingspan
these wings are the largest relative to
its body weight of any bird on the
planet
sailing close to the wind they can stay
aloft continuously for several days
and even sleep on the wing
they use thermals to soar up to 8 000
feet high
but graceful flight hides a dark side
these birds are merciless bandits
weighing up to four pounds they bully
other birds for food
with a reputation for extreme violence
it's no surprise they're known as the
man of war
isabel island
it's the mating season
this adult male frigate bird is back at
the colony after five months at sea
he pumps up his throat to show off
once he's got a mate he needs to build a
nest
and that is one enormous challenge
their huge wings make takeoffs and
landings difficult
they've learned it's easier to steal
twigs from other birds in mid-air
wind bandits attack each other from
every direction
but he's well placed below and snatches
a twig falling through the air
[Music]
finally he has a solid nest
and with an egg to guard he's sitting
pretty
but some latecomers believe that
building a nest is for suckers
both his home and bloodline are at stake
a winged destroyer targets him from
above
it spears him right down the center of
the throat
he neutralizes the attack
by clamping onto the invader's beak
so the challenger changes tactics
he targets the head from the side
and gains the nest
but only for a moment
because the wave of frigate fury never
lets up
a totally new rival swoops in
the incomer goes for the throat from
below
his beak has sharp edges
and measures over four inches long
its curved tip is designed for hooking
on to slippery fish
giving him a firm hold on any target
the incomer holds his neck tight
it's a move he can't counter
he's helpless and has to fly for his
life
the new nest owner quickly settles in
his first housekeeping task
is cold-blooded murder
in the cutthroat world of the man of war
there's no room for seabird sentiment
[Music]
claws and hook beaks are nothing
compared to a spike
and body armor
in the forests of madagascar
the plowshare tortoise was born to fight
built like an armored tank
with a single killer weapon
a hard plow-shaped spike poking out
between his front legs
and when they're feeling in the mood for
love
well nothing's going to get in their way
this casanova detects the smell of a
female in heat
she's playing hard to get
but he enjoys the chase
he circles
and sniffs at her to signal his
intentions
but when that pickup trick doesn't work
he turns to brute force
[Music]
he uses his impressive spike to render
her helpless
who said romance is dead
but before he can seal the deal
another suitor appears
and you can be sure that in a love
triangle between plowshare tortoises
things are going to get very nasty very
quickly
like medieval knights lining up for a
joust
the suitors eye each other up
the winner will get a chance to secure
his bloodline the loser will be history
[Music]
the intruder breaks ranks first
their lances clash
[Music]
both fighters are heavily armored
with a shell as hard as a human skull
top and bottom
and scaly armored skin on their legs
their only weak spot is the exposed soft
neck and shoulders between the shells
if either combatant can drive his spike
into this soft spot he could land a
decisive blow
casanova fails to penetrate the
intruder's armor
time for plan b
a tortoise flip
it's a winning move
in one fell swoop the intruder is
thoroughly
stuck all he can do is look on
humiliated as the victor claims his
reward
the chance to pass on his dna
from a small spike to one of the most
legendary and lethal horns on the planet
in the wide open spaces of the south
african bush there's plenty of room to
roam
but when these two giants see red
this place just isn't big enough for the
both of them
the white rhino of south africa is the
largest of the world's rhinos
and the most deadly
measuring six feet at the shoulder this
animal fight night heavyweight clocks in
at over five thousand pounds
his killer weapon is his horn it's made
of keratin and as hard as nails the
front one can reach three feet long
the african buffalo is also tooled up
with a set of horns
curled into a hook they are catch and
toss weapons
joined in the center in a thick bulge
called a boss
and they're backed up by a rock-hard
skull
which can kill with a single headbutt
also six feet at the shoulder he matches
the rhino for height
but at under two thousand pounds he's
less than half the weight of a white
rhino
despite their awesome weaponry
both these guys are grass eaters and
that's the problem
a white rhino is grazing on his home
range in the south african bush
he's spent his entire life here
but this buffalo wants a piece of the
territory
both these guys need to eat constantly
to survive
they square up
blood in their eyes
the rhino lunges
but the buffalo is lighter on his feet
both look for an opening
but the rhino seizes it
nearly two inches thick the buffalo's
skin holds out
just
he counters the attack but the rhino
makes his extra one and a half tons
count
his head and horn double as a heavy-duty
forklift truck
the rhino goes for the buffalo's tender
belly and throat
totally helpless the buffalo can't hook
on to the rhino
but buffalo don't let their buddies
battle alone
their herd mentality is strong
and his brothers are desperate to save
him
if he doesn't get away
he's finished
another buffalo steps in
his buddy deliberately targets his
trapped leg
with massive force he unhooks his
comrade from the rhino's deadly weapon
he's down
but he's free
time for everyone to make a break for it
the rhino wins the grazing rights
but a buffalo buddy up wins his victims
freedom
the dry plains of southern india are
crawling with venomous snakes
the spectacled cobra is one of the four
most deadly in southern asia
[Music]
they can reach up to seven feet long
and are pure biological weapons
a single bite can kill a human within
hours
sharing the planes is the indian grey
mongoose
just 30 inches long
and weighing up to 5 pounds
what they lack in size
they make up for in legendary ferocity
so when mongoose and cobra collide
it's one of the most savage showdowns on
animal fight night
this four-year-old male spectacled cobra
senses trouble
a two-year-old male mongoose is on the
prowl
and he's put snake on the menu
but he set himself a tall order
the cobra is in classic threat mode
his extended hood flashes skin patterns
designed to scare off predators
he can expand his hood by extending
movable ribs behind his neck from the
third down to the 13th vertebra
13 might be unlucky for some but this
crazy mongoose is up for the fight
the cobra plays to his strengths
he's flexible and can attack from many
different angles
he has two fangs in his mouth which can
deliver about 210 milligrams of deadly
venom
that's more than 13 times the amount
needed to kill a human
the snake can lunge at more than three
feet per second
but if he lunges and misses he's
directly in the firing line
these two masters face off in a deadly
dance of split-second timing
but the mongoose isn't just fabled for
his ultra-fast reflexes
he also holds a trump card
thanks to a unique adaptation the
mongoose is resistant to small doses of
cobra venom
whoever lands the first blow
will take all
the snakes desperate to keep the
mongoose at bay
both are tiring from the ultra-fast
combat
but the mongoose senses an opening
his greater reflexes take the edge
locking 40 needle-like teeth onto the
cobra skull
he crushes it
tenderizing the meat as he goes
and runs off to eat dinner in peace
life is tough three miles above sea
level on the tibetan plateau
it can reach minus 40 in winter
cold enough to freeze oil
the air is too thin for most humans to
breathe
but the tibetan antelope calls it home
to survive he has specialized blood
cells and some of the warmest wool of
the entire animal kingdom
but his biggest worry is another male's
two foot long flesh-piercing weapons
because when two males go head-to-head
they can fight to the death
tibet's high plateau
this six-year-old tibetan antelope is in
command of a harem of eight females
and he's in his prime
this four-year-old male thinks it's time
to dethrone the king
charging around at 50 miles per hour
shows off his fighting fitness
[Music]
the veterans all steamed up
the battle hardened pro has everything
to lose
the eager challenger everything to gain
the goal
battle head to head until they can twist
their opponent's neck and inflict a
potentially fatal broadside to an
exposed flank
the young buck tries to sneak in a clean
stab
but the wiley veterans aren't in
and these wickedly curved horns can kill
measuring around five inches at their
base their horns have a steely core of
hard bone which ends in a wickedly
curved stiletto-like tip
after a final flash of blades
the challenger tries a new tactic
blocking horns the youngster spins his
opponent around
their horns are not only sharp but also
have multiple ridges along their length
giving them a friction grip for intense
grappling
both antelopes struggle to deliver a
potentially fatal stab to the flanks
if they puncture a lung it could mean a
slow and agonizing death
the fate of the female antelopes hangs
in the balance
the veteran digs deep
anything to throw the young contender
off his game
now he's got him off balance
he looks for an opening
he executes his killer move
he twists and disengages with a shake he
forces his opponent's head down toward
the ground
humiliated the youngster receives a
master lesson in antelope swordplay
worn out and wounded
he retreats
he'll need to build up more strength
before he can mount a successful
challenge
the old master has hung on to his harem
until the next time
from a sword fight with deadly daggers
to a clash of savagery and legendary
cunning
the red box is a true survivor
found in every corner of the northern
hemisphere
they reach 35 inches long
and weigh up to 30 pounds
they have sharp slender canines over one
inch long
they hunt alone with a potential range
of over four square miles
sly and scheming
they're one of the most devious
contenders on animal fight night
between january and march
it's full-on fighting season
when adult males go head-to-head in do
or die battles that can be heard for
miles
[Music]
in the cold winter months in north
america
red fox passions run hot
foxes are normally nocturnal
but love waits for no one and a female
box attracts a local guy in broad
daylight
her howls also lure an outsider
but there can be only one winner
the outsider immediately targets the
local's legs
it's a key tactic
a broken leg could spell a death
sentence in the unforgiving wilderness
he protects his throat at all costs
if the local guy gets a clean bite
there's a chance you could sever the
outsider's windpipe or even tear an
artery
dueling up on their powerful hind legs
both go for the jugular
the outsider changes tactics
using the full force of his weight to
throw the local guy off balance
a split second error could cost him the
fight
another powerful push
but the outsider misses his crucial
chance
the local's just too quick
and he's clever
he uses the home advantage and seizes
the perfect defensive position back to
the snow slope facing downhill
crouched low his throat is protected but
now he can easily rip into the outsiders
the outsider knows it's hopeless
breeding rights go to the more cunning
local fox
and a victory jig marks his claim to the
female
devious strategy wins some fights
use stealth and savage claws against a
terrifying tag team
the dusty plains of southern africa
hunting grounds for the caracal
nearly 50 inches long and weighing up to
40 pounds they may not rank as a true
big cat
but with their natural stealth and
agility they're one of the world's most
efficient feline killers
their trademark tufted long ears can
locate prey in the rough terrain from
far away
with extreme muscle control
they creep up close to their victims
and leap up to ten feet in the air
snatching birds from the sky
this five-year-old male caracal picks up
the sound of some black-backed jackals
chewing on a carcass
he hasn't eaten in days and the chance
of a free meal is too good to miss
he can chase off a predator twice his
size
and is willing to face the odds of two
against one
up against a character a single jackal
wouldn't stand a chance
but there's strength in numbers they tag
team
nipping him with their sharp half-inch
canines
the caracal has the edge in accuracy and
power
but jackals pair for life
and these two are a well-honed
partnership
as one attacks his exposed hindquarters
he's forced to turn
leaving him open to a new assault from
behind
his attention is constantly divided
the jackals keep the pressure on
one bite from his one-inch canines could
rip their throats in two
his razor-sharp claws could easily
lacerate their flesh
but the team effort is paying off
the caracal retreats
and the jackals lower their state of
alert
but it's only a cunning feline bluff
he waits until they move away from the
carcass
and races in to claim it
the jackals returned to seize it back
[Music]
only now they have a big problem
the caracal holds the defender's
advantage
he's both eating and single-handedly
fending them off
there's not much more they can do but
circle him and launch intermittent
attacks
the dogs have had their day
it's time for the caracal to make off
with his loot
food is crucial
but the fight for a roof over your head
can be the difference between life and
death
the coasts of the americas are home to
hundreds of species of hermit crabs
these little critters are one of
nature's most resourceful survivors
their soft bodies aren't hard enough to
protect them from sharks and other
predators
so they wear recycled body armor instead
every crab's property is unique
but a perfect fit is important
as they develop to their full size
hermit crabs constantly look to trade up
to bigger properties as they outgrow the
old ones
they can move up to a hundred times
during their lifetime
a lucky crab may find a discarded shell
for a new home but most have to fight
for them
these are the most violent fights of a
crab's life
because finding yourself homeless
can be a death sentence
the coasts of north america
something's up on the ocean floor
hermit crabs are on the move
this giant horse conk is devouring a
tulip snail
[Music]
and the smell of snail flesh means one
thing to the hermit crab
a new home is coming up for grabs
the race to check out the new property
is on
but they proceed with caution
if they get too close
the conch could eat them too
[Music]
they jockey for position
waiting for the conch to spit out the
snail shell
their claws swing into action
this family of hermits have a larger
right pincer called the crusher
and the smaller left pincer called the
cutter
both are used to attack
the prospect of the new home just
seconds from release
triggers a frenzy
everyone wants to be the first in line
but this hermit hates to wait
taking a risk he scoots right inside the
snail shell before it's even left the
conch
the crabs are furious
[Music]
the new home is a perfect fit
and he quickly takes off to find a new
neighborhood
the takeover triggers a chain reaction
on the housing market as all the other
crabs rush to upgrade
time for a gladiator contest
beetle style
this three-week-old adult male caucasus
beetle is primed for a fight
three inches of glistening armor he's
one of the largest and strongest beetles
on earth
his horns are fighting weapons and can
account for fifty percent of his entire
body weight
he's only got a few weeks of life left
to pass on his dna
living in the jungles of borneo he set
up a bachelor pad full of food to
attract fertile females
but here comes trouble
another heavily armed outsized beetle
has his eye on the neighborhood
face to face they lock horns
the name of the game
a pure show of strength by knocking your
opponent off the log
it's a wrestling match
with the clock ticking
both contenders are equipped with three
horns made of a protein called chitin
they're extremely strong
and almost as hard and compact as bone
the intruder has the right idea
he comes from a lower angle and manages
to lift the other guy up in the air
he can lift a massive 850 times his own
body weight
but the homemaker clings on with all his
might
his feet are designed for the job
hooked claws called tarsie cover their
six feet
and are essential for gripping during
knockout fights
neither is gaining any ground
so it's time for the intruder to try a
new strategy
he goes for an over-the-top flip
but can't quite muster the power to pull
it off
it's a close call
evenly matched
the victor will have to dig deep to find
the added edge
the intruder recruits a natural partner
gravity
[Music]
the homemaker clings on with all he's
got
if he falls
it's game over
everything is at stake
it's a clear victory
the intruder celebrates
by climbing on to the winner's podium
and now with just weeks to live
every second counts to find himself a
mate
[Music]
you